nuit ont manifesté à paris pour réclamer
la réouverture de leur établissement
alors qu'un concert à nice rassemblant
des milliers de personnes suscite la
polémique
[Musique]
la colère monte au mali après les
violents affrontements ce week end à
bamako le président keita a dissous la
cour constitutionnelle contestée par la
rue
pas de quoi apaiser les tensions contre
le président accusé de passivité face à
l'insécurité et aux nombreux problèmes
sociaux
les violences ont fait huit morts et des
dizaines de blessés plusieurs figures de
l'opposition ont été arrêtés
élection présidentielle très disputée
aujourd'hui en pologne avec deux
candidats aux antipodes pour ce second
tour le sortant andré j'dida face au
maire de varsovie ils sont au coude à
coude
un scrutin aux allures de plébiscite
pour ou contre l'union européenne les
premiers résultats sont attendus dans
les heures qui viennent
[Musique]
et
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir ce premier
déplacement pour jean castex en guyane
toujours placées en état d' alerte
sanitaire une visite éclair pour faire
un état des lieux et tenté de rassurer
la population
toujours en proie aux coronavirus et il
n'a toujours pas atteint son pic avec un
manque de moyens hospitaliers qui
pourrait aggraver la situation
la population réclame des actes et
depuis cayenne
le premier ministre a félicité l'action
du précédent gouvernement
cette visite mesdames et messieurs
témoigne de ma volonté forte d'exprimer
à l'endroit de la guyane et de sa
population la solidarité le total
engagement de la république
j'ai en particulier tenu à m'assurer que
les éléments aussi structurant que les
capacités en réanimation
les dotations en masque en test était
suffisante et je prends devant vous
l'engagement que sous couvert de
monsieur le ministre de la santé
si des éléments nouveaux devait survenir
nous donnerions la guyane des moyens
nécessaires
la guyane qui n'est pas sorti d'affaires
loin de là le stade iii a été déclaré le
15 juin dernier alors que la métropole
passe et auvers près de 2600 cas selon
la rs et 29 morts avec une
intensification de la circulation du
virus constaté ilana a fait radiant
après un premier confinement la guyane
doit faire face à de nouvelles mesures
pour ralentir la propagation du
coronavirus reparti à la hausse ces
derniers jours tout comme chez son
voisin brésilien
le coc vite 19 a déjà contaminé près de
5000 personnes et fait une vingtaine de
morts dans la collectivité française
des chiffres qui risquent de se
multiplier d'ici les prochains jours la
guyane se prépare en effet à un pic
épidémique avant la fin du mois de
juillet face à l'inquiétude
le couvre-feu déjà en vigueur dans la
collectivité a été durci sur tout le
territoire
20 quartiers particulièrement pauvres de
l'île de cayenne ont ainsi été confinés
totalement l'état d'urgence sanitaire a
également été prolongée
jusqu'au 30 octobre en guyane par
conséquent les vols entre la région et
le reste du territoire français sont
désormais interdits enfin au coeur des
préoccupations se trouvent aussi les
services hospitaliers
le centre hospitalier de cayenne se
trouve aujourd'hui confrontée à un
afflux de plus en plus important de
patients qui oblige établissements à se
réorganiser au quotidien pour adapter
notamment la quantité de lits en
mesurant avec le milan des patients
commune pour pallier à la crise
plusieurs évacuations sanitaires de
malades ont déjà été réalisés vers la
guadeloupe et la martinique
un hôpital de campagne a par ailleurs
été installé au centre hospitalier de
cayenne
son objectif accueillir des patients non
qu'ovide l'installation de cet hôpital
de campagne fusent dans les à côté de
l'hôpital va nous permettre de dédoubler
notre circuit d'accueil des urgences et
donc de le sécuriser
dans nos urgences actuelles en
accueillera les urgences covin et les
urgences mais non kobina seront
accueillis dans l'hôpital de campagne
on va véritablement sécuriser les
parcours patient de son côté l'état
poursuit son soutien notamment en aide
alimentaire d'urgence selon la
préfecture de guyane 19000 sur blues 5
respirateur 10000 gants et des masques
ffp2 vont arriver d'ici les prochains
jours une soixantaine de personnels du
ministère de la santé est aussi attendue
ce week end
pas suffisant selon les habitants de
l'île dans un communiqué l'association
médecins du monde
alerte également à la fois sur la
fragilité du système de santé guyanais
et sur le risque d'une crise sociale
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
prolongée jusqu'au 30 octobre 2020 en
guyane contrairement à la métropole les
droits sociaux comme l'accès à
l'assurance maladie n'ont pas été
prolongés à nouveau ce qui va constituer
un blocage majeur d'accès aux soins pour
les personnes en situation de précarité
un appel à l'aide
reste à savoir si le gouvernement
français l'entendra et il y a urgence et
ce que dit en tout cas ivan goût à elle
et porte-parole du collectif mayouri
santé guyane mais elle ne se fait pas
beaucoup d'illusions sur le déplacement
de jean castex écouter depuis les deux
semaines où on a réussi à les obtenir
alors ça fait deux mois qu'on les
réclames abbas et 20 personnes par
semaine 20 personnes par semaine et donc
du coup comment voulez vous gérer une
crise sans précédent 5700 cas pour une
population de 300 milles c'est ça nulle
part ailleurs on est même au dessus
aujourd'hui en termes de par habitant je
parviens par habitant d'impact de la
crise on est au dessus aujourd'hui delà
de la chine
on est au dessus de l'italie et pourtant
on n'a pas les moyens en adéquation donc
vingt personnes arrivent par semaine
alors qu'il faut en fait aujourd'hui il
manque à peu près 300 à 400
professionnels soignants en guyane en
n'attends rien du tout parce que il
vient sont un territoire 8h15 il va
faire très exactement 8h15 sur leur
territoire il va passer il paraît un
moment convivial avec nos élus 1 alors
que nous sommes en crise sanitaire et
qu'il y a des gens qui meurent en a 23
décès en même pas aujourd'hui à moi donc
aujourd'hui on n'entend rien de spécial
le gouvernement décidément très présent
sur le terrain
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
s'est rendu aujourd'hui à calais
accompagné de marlène schiappa
nouvellement nommés ministres délégués
de la citoyenneté
deux jours après le démantèlement d'un
camp de migrants gérald darmanin a
rencontré la mère de la ville natacha
bouchart il a également signé un accord
avec son homologue britannique sur la
création d'une cellule de renseignement
franco britannique afin de mieux lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs nous
avons conclu que nous devons nous revoir
très prochainement sans doute avant le
début du mois d'août j'irai à londres à
son invitation pour rendre compte des
derniers arrangements que nous pourrions
mettre en place pour que très rapidement
la situation que nous connaissons se
transforme avec davantage d'effectifs
davantage de matériel davantage de
protection pour la côte littorale de
l'ensemble des hauts de france
je pense qu'il est très important c'est
que nos amis britanniques prennent
conscience que si les migrants viennent
ici à calais c'est pas simplement pour
la beauté de la ville de calais c'est
aussi pour passer de l'autre côté de la
manche
et on a rappelé à madame la ministre
qu'il a entendu et je l'en remercie que
nous avons besoin de moyens
supplémentaires
le gouvernement britannique a fait
beaucoup pour la protection du littoral
nous avons encore besoin davantage de
moyens tant pour le matériel ou pour des
hommes et nous allons rediscuter de tout
cela avant le 1er août à paris les
professionnels du monde de la nuit ont
manifesté aujourd'hui pour réclamer la
réouverture de leur établissement ils
sont fermés depuis le 11 mars à cause de
la crise sanitaire et ils se sont réunis
vous le voyez devant le ministère de la
santé ils ont lancé un appel à l'aide au
gouvernement sans espoir d'une
réouverture prochaine de nombreux
établissements risquent de fermer
définitivement
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter thomas bonnin plusieurs
centaines de participants à ce
rassemblement à quelques pas du
ministère de la santé des professionnels
du monde de la nuit qui souhaitent
alerter sur l'état de santé financière
de leur secteur les discothèques sont
fermés depuis le 17 mars dernier et
elles ne rouvriront pas comme prévu en
tout cas comme il était espéré au mois
de juillet c'est ce qu'a annoncé cette
semaine olivier rend le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé je propose de
l'écouter la france
a pris la décision de ne pas rouvrir la
discothèque en l'état compte tenu de la
situation sanitaire et des risques ce
n'est pas la faute des acteurs du monde
de la nuit
ce n'est pas non plus la faute des
personnes qui danse et qui font la fête
et on peut parfaitement le comprendre
ce n'est là c'est la faute à un virus
c'est la faute à un virus qui circule et
des conditions qui permettent au virus
de se transmettre et de mettre en danger
tout le plan de levée du confinement qui
a été réussie mis en oeuvre par le
premier ministre alors qu'il n'était pas
encore premier ministre
pas de réouverture donc on parle
désormais d'une possible réouverture des
établissements nuit d'ici septembre
voire octobre et cela serait un drame
financier pour un certain nombre
d'établissements puisque ils ne peuvent
donc pas recevoir du public
ils reçoivent des aides de la part du
gouvernement mais beaucoup de gérants
d'établissements nuit nous explique que
ce n'est absolument pas suffisant pour
couvrir l'intégralité de leurs charges
il demande donc une perspective
peut-être d'être reçu par le
gouvernement et je propose donc
d'écouter quelques uns des participants
à ce rassemblement
c'est au micro de cynthia l'auberge on
représente 1600 entreprises mission
entreprise de la nuit en très grosse
difficultés à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
puisque bas il n'y a pas d'ouverture
possible et une envie d une ouverture
envisageable peut-être octobre voire
novembre ce qui est impossible pour nous
pour résister c'est un impact économique
déjà puisque c'est au représentent
quasiment cinquante mille personnes
cinquante mille personnes qui seront
demain au chômage 50 me les personnes
qui demain devront faire vivre leur
famille difficulté incohérente et ce que
nous on comprends pas c'est que des des
animations se font également dans les
dents les appartements se font dans la
rue et nous on survit et là c'est la
mort certaine nous on n'a pas de
perspective d d'ouverture on n'a pas des
aides on n'a rien on est la seule
profession le seul corps des métiers où
nous laisse comme ça sans rien rien rien
nouvel arrêté de fermeture qui va
jusqu'au 30 octobre
est ce qu'on sera ouvert avant le 30
octobre après que 30 octobre on sait pas
le gouvernement nous balade depuis
quatre mois tous les quinze jours avec
une nouvelle ouverture qui vient pas on
est là voilà donc à terme ces dépôts de
bilan pour la majorité d'entre nous pour
ce rassemblement il avait été demandé
aux participants de s'habiller en blanc
blanc couleurs de la fête mais aussi des
marches blanches et c'est en quelque
sorte le
de la nuit qu'on est en train d'enterrer
nous confié un des participants à monde
de la nuit déjà impactés par différents
événements ces dernières années les
attentats dans la capitale ou encore les
mouvements sociaux ce qui choque aussi
les professionnels du monde de la nuit
qui sont présents ici ce sont les images
qui circulent sur les réseaux sociaux
le rassemblement hier soir à nice par
exemple mais aussi les soirées qui sont
organisées dans les appartements ou dans
les bars il estime que ce sont les plus
à même de recevoir du public au sein de
leur établissement et ce tout en
respectant les mesures sanitaires et
puis point un peu plus symbolique mais
qui choque ici aussi c'est la tenue
demain soir à paris d'une soirée au
grand palais en l'honneur des personnels
soignants reçu par le ministre de la
santé
olivier vers ans alors c'est évidemment
pas le fait que le personnel soignant
soit célébrée de la sorte qui choque ici
c'est plutôt le fait que au moment où il
est interdit aux établissements de nuit
de rouvrir et bien on autorise une
soirée en plein coeur de la capitale
incompréhension des personnels de la
nuit alors qu'à nice 5000 personnes ont
assisté à un concert sur la promenade
des anglais nous voyait est la mairie se
défend de toute négligence elle assure
avoir respecté la réglementation
sanitaire
le maire de nice christian estrosi a
d'ailleurs demandé une clarification de
ses consignes au gouvernement
l'événement d'hier à nice respecter les
consignes gouvernementales comme l'a
indiqué la préfecture
comptage pour respect de la jauge de
5000 consignes de distanciation rappeler
via messages audio et signalétique et
masques fortement recommandée nous
regrettons que ces consignes n'ait pas
été suffisamment respectés et demandons
à l'état de revoir le décret qui régit
les grands événements afin d'imposer le
port du masque même à l'extérieur
à nice il sera désormais obligatoire
pour tous nos événements
un concert qui fait polémique alors que
plusieurs médecins ont signé aujourd'hui
une tribune dans la presse ils demandent
au gouvernement de rendre le port du
masque obligatoire dans tous les lieux
publics clos une tribune de 14 médecins
urgentistes qui appelle également à
respecter bien sûr la distanciation
physique
la france qui compte plus de 70 foyers
de contamination à ce jour notamment en
mayenne où une grande campagne de
dépistage va débuter à partir de demain
et puis en espagne plusieurs personnes à
signer de nouveau à domicile en
catalogne sur ordre des autorités de la
région à cause d'une forte hausse du
nombre de cas de contamination
la zone concernée compte plus de deux
cent mille habitants elle avait déjà été
isolé du reste de la catalogne samedi
dernier la colère monte au mali après
les violents affrontements ce week end à
bamako le président keita a dissous la
cour constitutionnelle contestée par la
rue
pas de quoi apaiser pour autant les
tensions contre le président il est
toujours accusé de passivité face à
l'insécurité et aux nombreux problèmes
sociaux du pays
les violences ont fait huit morts et des
dizaines de blessés et plusieurs figures
de l'opposition ont été arrêtés clément
hospital et cyrielle beaux et ils
n'auront pas obtenu sa démission mais
dans l'espoir de ramener le calme dans
la capitale malienne
le président ibrahim boubacar keïta a
annoncé samedi soir la dissolution de la
cour constitutionnelle
après plusieurs jours d'intenses
manifestations j'ai donc décidé
d'abroger des décrets de nomination des
membres restants de la cour
constitutionnelle est d'aller vers la
mise en oeuvre des recommandations
issues de la mission de la cedeao du
continuerait de privilégier le dialogue
avec toutes les forces vives de la
nation pour la mise en place d'une
équipe gouvernementale consensuel
composés de quadrilles polkas et
patriotes et non de casseurs et des
militaires du pays le mali boys mieux
que ça depuis vendredi au moins huit
personnes ont été tuées et une
cinquantaine blessées au cours des
manifestations les arrestations se
multiplient également dans les rangs de
l'opposition
plusieurs figures de la contestation
issu du mouvement m 5 ont été
interpellés après avoir appelé à la
désobéissance civile
nous restons mobilisés parce que la
répression en force la détermination et
nous allons continuer avec notre régime
imeca qui est raffermie pour tout le
monde
aux abords d'un véhicule calciné devant
l'assemblée nationale
des centaines de manifestants appellent
à la démission du bk le président malien
ibrahim boubacar keïta c'est une colère
qui éclatent au grand jour cristallisé
par le couvre-feu imposé dans le cadre
des mesures adoptées contre le
coronavirus ou encore les élections
législatives de mars et avril dont les
résultats sont toujours contestées
nous sommes là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
notre pays nous sommes là on est dans un
pays en proie au djihadisme depuis 2012
aux violences intercommunautaires et à
une économie en berne
cette contestation fait craindre aux
alliés du mali une nouvelle
déstabilisation dans une région très
tourmentée et voyez à présent l'analyse
dali toukara il est sociologue et
directeur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sahel
les causes profondes de ce mouvement et
m5
quant à son émergence c'est lié au fait
que les différentes réponses apportées
par les quelqu'un du paysan qu ils sache
n'est pas sécuritaire 1 à satisfaire les
différentes réponses apportées par les
enquêtes sur les plans mais mehdi katif
nous allons combler les attentes qu'ont
les malins visage l'éducation
actuellement ce sont toutes ces stars
n'a pas de métal sans talc expliquer
toute la légitimité de ce mouvement est
10ème 5 de chances que son départ au
pouvoir et quand même mal perçue par le
nombre important des moyens mais
beaucoup souhaité aujourd'hui qu'il
apporte des réponses courageuses
lesquels éléphants street a même fait
entorse à certaines poches d'une
notamment la leaf entre de l'assemblée
nationale et puis au burkina faso pays
frontalier du mali
le président en exercice vient d'être
investi par son parti comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
à 63 ans roch marc christian kaboré va
donc briguer un deuxième mandat de cinq
ans malgré un bilan controversé
notamment sur le plan sécuritaire avec
de nombreuses attaques dualiste il était
l'unique candidat à l'investiture de son
camp le scrutin aura lieu en novembre
moi et parmi ses futurs adversaires
l'ancien premier ministre kadré désiré
ouédraogo ou encore eddie komboïgo le
président du congrès pour la démocratie
et le progrès le cdp de l'ex président
blaise compaoré jour de vote en pologne
un second tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui s'annonce serré entre
le chef de l'état conservateur sortant
andré joda et le maire libéral
pro-européen de varsovie les deux hommes
sont au coude à coude dans les sondages
le vote des jeunes pourraient faire la
différence
une élection tout cas qui divise les
polonais regarder je vote pour rafal
trajkovski parce que nous sommes
fatigués des cinq dernières années de
présidence d'andré j'dida je pense que
beaucoup de choses se sont améliorées
durant le règne de duda parce que j'ai
une augmentation de salaire il ya
d'autres programmes sociaux comme ceux
pour les enfants et je pense qu'il a
beaucoup fait pour les pauvres
j'aimerais bien sûr que la pologne soit
un pays qui tolèrent différents points
de vue mais aussi où tout le monde se
sent en sécurité
je pense que certaines sociétés ne sont
pas prêtes pour cela maintenant sera
évoqué les 17 et 18 juillet prochain
lors du prochain conseil européen et il
sera question des réformes judiciaires
adoptée par le parti droit et justice
qui est au pouvoir
mais cela concerne la création d'une
chambre judiciaire dédié à la discipline
des magistrats
depuis 2010 est l'exécutif européen a
engagé quatre procédures d'infraction
contre ces réformes controversées
cinquième nuit consécutive de
manifestation à belgrade en serbie des
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées vous voyez pour protester
contre la gestion du gouvernement de la
crise sanitaire
il l'a jugée incohérente mardi l'
annonce d'un confinement par le
président a mis le feu aux poudres
pour beaucoup alexander gucci cha a
minimisé l'ampleur de la pandémie pour
servir
elle ses intérêts électoraux l'actualité
internationale
en bref et en images à présent en
bulgarie le chef de l'état demande la
démission de son gouvernement il le
qualifie de mafio le cabinet
conservateur et son premier ministre
sont accusés par l'opposition d'avoir
provoqué des perquisitions au siège de
la présidence bulgare est ainsi
d'attaquer le président en exercice
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu relance
l'aide humanitaire transfrontalières en
syrie mais il n'y aura pas deux mais un
seul point de passage
il passera par la région d'idlib une
condition qui avait été souhaitée par la
russie pour préserver la souveraineté du
territoire syrien
bab al hawa c'est le point de passage en
question il dessert la région d'idlib il
se situe à la frontière avec la turquie
et il pourrait donc être utilisé pour
une durée d'un an
le pape françois a réagi aujourd'hui à
la décision du président tueur de
transformer la basilique sainte-sophie
en mosquée le souverain pontife s'est
dit très affligé le monument qui serait
ouvert aux prières musulmanes à partir
du 24 juillet prochain désormais en
israël d'ailleurs la nuit dernière au
cours d'une manifestation à tel-aviv
contre les conséquences économiques dues
à la crise du coronavirus bilan au moins
dix neuf arrestations plusieurs milliers
d'israéliens qui se sont mobilisés vous
le voyez pour dénoncer également la
gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement un rassemblement organisé
par des groupes de travailleurs
indépendants des petites entreprises
mais aussi des artistes alors que le
pays compte plus de 36000 cas + 2 350
décès écoutez win it solutions
nous avons besoin de solutions beaucoup
de gens parlent on ait aucun ne fait ce
qu'il promet nous avons besoin d'argent
je suis dans le monde du tourisme et en
israël
le monde du tourisme et s'effondre parce
que nous n'avons pas de fonds s'il n'y a
pas de fonds pour les entreprises et
leurs employés ni pour les entreprises
qui luttent pour survivre
nous avons dû dire au monde qui serait
l'effort nous sommes la start up nation
nous avons besoin de dire au monde que
nous rouvrons l'aéroport ben gourion et
koons et dans l'économie à prospecter
nous demandons au gouvernement de nous
verser des compensations pour notre
période de fermeture afin que nous
puissions reprendre notre activité nous
remettre au travail
j'ai fermé mon frère j'ai viré tous mes
employés et nous sommes tous chez nous
sans argent du tout et voyez l'analyse à
présent de pierre ray of reporter
écrivain et réalisateur de documentaires
sur place après deux mois pratiquement
de confinement ont postulé pour
possibilité que pâques non seulement en
israël un peu partout dans le monde les
gens vont quand même un peu ras-le-bol
maintenant concernant astral plus
précisément on a extrêmement bien géré
la première vague et c'est pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une espèce de
surprises
mais en réalité le problème c'est que la
sortie de la crise a été beaucoup trop
rapide et du bureau romain pratiquement
tout a été rouvert les gens se sont dit
ça y est c'est fini et puis maintenant
on est reparti avec pratiquement biais
de 1300 4500 km en une journée ce
week-end des mesures à prendre et est
extrêmement difficile à prendre peut pas
sans arrêt systématique m'en remettre
mettre la faute sur une seule natanyahou
encore que il est un set dans cette
histoire là beaucoup de torts mais la
réalité c'est que la crise
gouvernementale s'est ajouté aux
problèmes que l'on avait des corps n'a
eu promet conomique en a aujourd'hui
aux etats unis cette première apparition
de donald trump avec un masque sur le
visage jusqu'ici le président américain
a toujours refusé d'adopter les gestes
barrière retour en images sur ses prises
de positions plutôt controversé
[Musique]
quand vous êtes dans un hôpital en
particulier dans ce cas où vous parlez à
de nombreux soldats et à des personnes
qui dans certains cas viennent juste de
sortir de la salle d'opération je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose de porter
un masque
je n'ai jamais été contre les masques
mais je pense qu'il y a un temps et un
lieu pour les porter
[Musique]
personnellement je ne veux pas emporté 1
c'est une recommandation
il leur commande je me sens bien je n'ai
pas envie d'être assis dans le bureau
ovale derrière ce beau bureau solennel
le grand bureau solennel et porter un
masque facial pour saluer les présidents
les premiers ministres les dictateurs
les rois les reines je ne sais pas je ne
le sens pas pour moi c'est juste que
peut-être que je vais changer d'avis
[Musique]
j'en ai porté un jean portait en tout à
l'heure à l'arrière mais je ne voulais
pas donner aux journalistes le plaisir
de le voir mais non je l'avais à
l'arrière j'ai porté un masque
[Musique]
cela pourrait expliquer pourquoi
l'europe n'aime pas porter un masque en
public
by donne aujourd'hui
[Musique]
pouvez vous enlevez votre masque je ne
vous entendra reparler plus fort ok
voulait être politiquement correct
malaisie
[Musique]
et comme quoi tout arrive c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité prochain journal dans 30
minutes rester avec nous
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins qu'on se rend compte que les
personnes en suède